gordon lost the handle picked up by
james back to caruso
throws it up hammer time for lebron
james
two-man game with caruso good pass and
james
hammers one home i would say he's okay
yeah lakers down 11. lebron a spin
lebron with a finish wow
it's just only a couple are as good as
lebron and his size his speed
and really more important his vision
thank you james james goes inside the
flush and the foul
about to play the pass and lebron james
about to win another title
kuzma gives it right back lebron takes
the pass lebron with some spin
oh my goodness how did he finish that
and one lebron james and it's knocked
away by caruso
up ahead rondo all the way lebron
james throws it down that was risky
james drives gets inside running layup
it's good out of foul
lebron james ties the game and a chance
for a three-point play
get the ball in the hands of lebron
james grown man
what an epic duel two mastable
performers
two great competitors picked up by james
back to caruso throws it up
hammer time for lebron james
i mean the steal mike bring calling for
hammer time stood his ground
lebron punches that into the family
section
he's playing with a sense of urgency
didn't give up on the play which is so
crucial white side made some very big
plays in game one alley-oop to james
and there's anthony davis with a perfect
pass because this is a setup you got to
see it of your places they allow a
direct dive to the cup on point pass
from anthony davis lebron
james on a mission
lebron with your chest
good feed from caruso lebron running the
lane
grown man move what up it's your boy
adam lefkow do you like that content i
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report